one of my absolute Heroes quent and
Tarantino I adore Tarantino films and
always always always dreamed of being in
a Tarantino film that is like always
been a bucket list so you like pend a
letter yeah I'm I'm a very analog person
I write everything down I do everything
handwritten um but I also know that he
writes you know he's a very analog
person like only has a home phone you
know I you know obviously read
everything there is to read about him so
I thought he'd appreciate a let him more
than an email plus I like I don't even
know if he has email I don't know if he
does that and it worked thank God he got
that letter right after finishing
writing Once Upon a Time in Hollywood